This episode is sponsored by Endel, an app
that creates personalized soundscapes to help
you focus, relax and sleep.The first 100 people
to click our description link will get a one week free trial.
James, our master of microscopes,
is not a farmer.
He is, to put it simply, fascinated by microbes.
And that may lead him to strange places and
cause him to grow tanks full of weird things.
But he is not a farmer.
So why did James, master of microscopes that
he is, decide to put a sweet potato in a tank?
Well, I guess you could say he was trying
to rescue it.
This poor, neglected sweet potato had reached
the point of inedibility, with sprouts growing all over it.
So it seemed right to give the
sweet potato some space of its own,
and let it live a little.
For James, the inevitable conclusion was to
put the sweet potato into a tank.
And here it is, thriving as its sprouts grow
tall and its roots bury deep.
There are times when James can even spot the
sprouts trying to escape the seal on the tank.
Maybe he would let them burst out, but the
tank is currently full of mosquitos,
so for now it stays sealed.
The mosquitos are a story for
another day.
Today, we’re here for the sweet potato because
it has a very important job, one that it probably
never anticipated having.
This sweet potato is going to be a stand-in
for one of the most important chemical and
biological processes in our world: nitrogen
fixation.
Let’s start by taking a tour of the sweet
potato’s roots.
Imagine that instead of the tank water that
they’ve been in, that you’re instead watching
the roots from where they would usually be:
buried in the soil.
You might see a scene like this, a crowd of
countless bacteria traveling towards the root
and away from it.
Some are shaped like tiny rods, and others
are spherical.
And some form filaments that trail off like
threads.
As you look around the root, you can see these
bacteria latch onto the root, almost as if
they’re a part of the plant’s own texture.
And along the root, you might find organisms like
this Nostoc, a cyanobacteria that can even be
found on plants like cycads that have above-ground
roots.
The clinginess of Nostoc is important to plants—and
actually to all of us—because they can do
nitrogen fixation.
What is that? Well it's a concept that comes
up often on our channel.
We talk about microbes that have an outsized
impact on our world through their role in
translating atmospheric nitrogen into chemical
forms that plants can actually use.
But we’ve never really dived into what that
means and why it’s so important.
It all comes down to the fact that nitrogen
is both essential and abundant,
and yet difficult to get.
When we think of the chemistry of life and
of humans and of our planet’s atmosphere,
our attention often gets
focused on oxygen, and carbon-dioxide.
But nitrogen is the majority of our atmosphere,
and it is extremely important.
Nitrogen is essential to making amino acids
and nucleic acids, and those are important things.
So if all of the nitrogen in the world were
to disappear in an instant,
we would not have protein.
We would not have DNA.
We wouldn’t have the fundamental
building blocks that make life on this earth possible.
Which, for the record,
I think, would be bad.
And this is true for all life.
This is something that we have in
common with the sweet potato.
We all need nitrogen.
Fortunately, as I said before, nitrogen is
abundant.
Around 78% of our atmosphere is made of
nitrogen gas.
So we should be good.
Right?
Well, no.
The problem is that nitrogen gas is diatomic
nitrogen, two atoms of nitrogen
bonded together, and that's just far too stable.
It’s hard for our bodies to break the bonds
between those nitrogens and convert them into
the forms we need, which is why we need eat other
animals and plants that have nitrogen.
But plants have the same problem as us.
They can’t turn all that nitrogen in the
atmosphere into forms that they can use.
But unlike us, plants have a secret weapon.
The things that we’ve been watching
throughout this video: microbes.
These microbes—these nitrogen-fixing microbes—are
special because they have an enzyme called
nitrogenase.
This enzyme catalyzes the break-up of that
strong bond holding nitrogen gas together,
freeing up the nitrogens to become ingredients
in more accessible chemicals like ammonia.
There's one catch though: nitrogenase stops
working completely when it’s exposed to oxygen.
So nitrogen-fixing organisms have a
few options for how to live.
Many of them live in anaerobic conditions,
where the lack of oxygen means their vital
enzyme will be safe.
And other organisms, like the cyanobacteria
we’ve been looking at, create their own
internal forms of protection, sequestering
the nitrogenase into specialized cells called
heterocysts.
You can see the heterocysts standing out like
special green beads on this dolichospermum,
which is a kind of cyanobacteria.
They’re super obvious rounder and larger
than the other cells within
the cyanobacteria  filament.
And they look so different because they need
thick walls so that oxygen can’t pass through,
which allows the nitrogenase to do its thing.
But these nitrogen-fixing microbes don’t
keep the nitrogen for themselves.
Bound to the roots of plants, they give some
of what they’ve made up in exchange for
other nutrients that the plants have made.
Nitrogen-fixation isn’t the only way that
plants get their nitrogen.
There’s also fertilizer, the death and decay
of other living organisms, and even lightning,
which can shatter the bonds of atmospheric
nitrogen and set up its conversion into other forms.
Like any other element, nitrogen’s journey
through our ecosystems takes many twists and
turns, setting up delicate balances and potentially
dire consequences.
Too little nitrogen, and life can’t happen.
Too much, and you can choke off lakes
as the thriving plants and algae eventually
reach the limits of what their ecosystem can
support.
It’s this interplay of nitrogen among so
many other elements that births, kills, and sustains.
It travels through our atmosphere, our soils,
our lakes, our bodies…and ends up, sometimes,
at the root of a strange, rescued sweet potato
sprouting in a mosquito-filled tank.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to Endel for sponsoring
this episode.
Endel is an app that takes everything we know
about sound, and combines it with technology,
and creates personalized soundscapes to help
you focus, relax, and sleep.Their app was
named the Apple Watch App of the Year in 2020
and they have a brand new soundscape called
Wind Down that they made in collaboration
with James Blake.
The goal of Wind Down is to help you transition
from an active day to a calmer state, so it’s
great just before bed too.
Sound has a direct impact on your physical
and mental wellbeing, and by adapting in real-time
to things like your location, weather, and
heart rate, Endel creates simple, pleasant
sounds that can help to calm your mind.
If you’re interested in trying out Endel,
just be one of the first 100 people to download
it using the link in the description and you
will get a free week of audio experiences!
Thank you so much to all the people on
screen right now.
They are our patrons on Patreon, and they
are the reason we are able to make
Journey to the Microcosmos.
The reason we are able to put a sweet potato
into a tank of mosquitos.
And the reason, that later you will find out,
what those mosquitos are all about.
If you want to become one of those people,
check out Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes, James Weiss.
You can check out Jam & Germs
on Instagram and TikTok.
And if you want to see more from us.
There is always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby.